you cannot build a perfect product from
day one the key lesson is like iterate
faster it often and no matter what stage
always talk to customers
we are building payments infrastructure
for small businesses focused on trucking
and transportation globally we are
trying to build better plumbing and
better core payments so that the small
businesses in trucking and
transportation don't have to think about
payments
[Music]
we're originally working on something
completely different we were trying to
build a commuter service we were trying
to match small business bus operators
with commuters and starting in the Bay
Area that was our original idea and then
covid head and nobody was commuting so
we decided to Pivot and uh you know from
our conversations with bus operators
they talked about how payments are
broken and we were very surprised
because in 2020 we weren't expecting to
hear that as a statement you know
there's companies like Stripes Square
PayPal brexit Ram just so many companies
that are fixing payments and and we
weren't expecting to hear that so we
decided to drive up to truck stops and
interview truck drivers and we did that
for several weeks give them Amazon gift
cards to talk to us and tell us about
how Fleet cards or payroll and other
other payments work and what what they
don't like about them and so for them we
heard just in a lot of things and horror
stories from drivers getting stuck in
the middle of nowhere at 3am because
their fuel card has downtime and so
that's why we wanted to build something
significantly better that serves this
very key in industry truck driving is
the number one profession in most most
U.S states since it's truly like the
backbone of the economy and suffers from
very Legacy Financial infrastructure
I've been a Founder before although I
was a solo founder and it was like a
much smaller Initiative for sure I tried
to essentially build a company around
cryptocurrency price tracking and
portfolio management that was my first
startup and it grew quite a lot and then
I sold it to a small private Equity Fund
then came to the US from India where I
grew up and started a to be here
currently we're around 10 or 12 million
ARR we're projecting to be between 16 to
18 by end of this year then we have 25
000 plus companies using us so we have
about 125 000 drivers across them
our Founders Journey has been quite
interesting originally when we were
doing the buses idea and we raised the
seed round with Bloomberg beta who was
our lead investor then and has been like
investing in every round since then for
us the keeping and fundraising was to
get people that understand the industry
in the space and can be very helpful
mentors to us so in every round you know
in series a we took we had a higher term
sheet but we took the lower term sheet
from General Catalyst because the
partner General Catalyst hay month had a
lot of experience being on the board of
stripe and samsara Augusto so like three
very relevant companies you know
payments Trucking and payroll and so we
wanted him as a mentor knowing that he
could help us create more long-term
value so we've always prioritized like
strong investors who understand the
space and can be and can help the
company grow and help with our problems
as opposed to the highest price
foreign
[Music]
I think we're working on a very
meaningful problem or that we're very
passionate about as well and you
encounter a lot of tech companies that
are trying to build you know products
for other Enterprises other technology
companies Etc and there's just so many
people trying to do that and very few
people trying to help small businesses
which is where most of wealth creation
really happens and it's it's very
impactful to solve their problems so I
think the impact or the Legacy that we
want to have or that I want to have is
to build a significantly better payments
infrastructure for these small
businesses so that they can focus on
what they're good at which is like
shipping loads hiring drivers and not
worrying about payments
[Music]
thank you